.
Acht Tage, 76 km
und fast 6'000 Höhenmeter -
das Dach Afrikas.
Drei Frauen und drei Männer
erfüllen sich ihren Lebenstraum:
ein Trekking
auf den 5'895 m hohen Kilimandscharo.
Eine Herausforderung
mit vielen Hürden.
Auf die Füsse schauen!
- Ah, verdammt!
Ich bin doch nie krank.
Ein kolossales Erlebnis.
Was die Porters hier leisten,
ist heftigste Arbeit.
Und eine Erfahrung,
die alle an ihre Grenzen bringt.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Der Kilimandscharo liegt in Tansania.
Er ist der höchste Berg Afrikas.
An seinem Fuss liegt
die kleine Streusiedlung Marangu.
Diese sechs Menschen aus der Schweiz
wagen das Abenteuer.
Kurt Hegglin
organisiert seit 35 Jahren
Trips auf den Kilimandscharo
und führt die Neuankömmlinge
in seine zweite Heimat ein.
Schau, er kauft Mais.
Warte!
Es wird schwierig:
Ich habe ihm 10'000 gegeben,
das sind rund 4 Fr.
Jetzt muss er
Retourgeld organisieren.
Das hat natürlich keinen Geschmack.
- Eher nicht.
Wir müssen hier ohne Salz auskommen.
- Zeig deine Muckis.
Den bekommst du
nicht weiter auseinander.
Doch, schon.
Nicht so intensiv und süss
wie bei uns.
Es ging extrem schnell
mit dem Retourgeld.
Ich bin total überrascht.
Thank you very much.- Yes.
Ich würde da jetzt
noch Butter draufstreichen.
Die sechs
kennen sich erst seit einem Tag.
Das Einzige, was sie verbindet,
ist ihr gemeinsames Ziel.
Dafür nimmst du den Haken.
- Den Reisbesen dort?
Weisst du, den.
- Ja.
Noch etwas breiter vielleicht.
Hello, baby.
- Oh, jetzt wird er pink.- Ja.
Komm, du kannst in die Haare.
Der geht sicher noch hoch.
Komm!
Ein fairer Preis wäre 5 Fr.
It's too big.
Der erste Tag
ist Akklimatisierungstag.
Marangu liegt auf 1'800 m ü.M.
Die meisten Einwohner
leben vom Tourismus.
* Suaheli *
Auf dem Markt
trifft Bergführer Priskus Peter
die letzten Vorbereitungen
für das achttägige Trekking.
Mit dabei: sein Küchenchef Eduard
und seine Frau Lucy.
Wir brauchen Gemüse und Früchte,
etwa 40 kg.
Wir sind eine grosse Gruppe.
* Suaheli *
Auch die Filmcrew
muss verpflegt werden.
Das sind acht Leute zusätzlich.
Gemüse wird in den nächsten Tagen
das Hauptnahrungsmittel sein.
Alle Träger, die ganze Crew am Berg,
die habe ich angeheuert.
Wenn etwas fehlt, z.B. Essen,
schauen alle mich an.
Wenn den Kunden etwas fehlt,
schauen auch alle mich an.
Ich bin verantwortlich für alles
und muss sichergehen,
dass ich genügend Lebensmittel
für die Träger habe,
genügend Lebensmittel für
die Kunden, genügend Zelte für alle,
sodass es alle geniessen können.
* Suaheli *
Auch Früchte dürfen nicht fehlen.
Wenn ich Schweizer habe,
kaufe ich Mangos und Ananas.
Ich weiss, dass sie das sehr mögen.
Die Gruppe in Marangu
deckt sich mit Coca-Cola ein.
Ein Tipp von Kurt,
falls der Magen Probleme macht.
Hat es auch Zero?
Ich und Damaris mögen keine Cola.
Es ist nur zur Not, wenn es dir mies
geht, würde ich eine Cola nehmen.
Wahrscheinlich
brauchst du es gar nicht.
Einfach als Notfallmedizin.
- Ja, genau.
(Sandra) Friert Cola nicht ein?
- Ihr müsst sie gut einpacken.
Einfach frühzeitig trinken.
- Nicht vor dem Zelt lassen.
Im Zelt kann es nicht einfrieren.
In den Schlafsack nehmen?
- Im Zelt ist es nicht unter 0 °C.
Er braucht es nicht.
- Das stimmt.- Weiter geht's.
Viele Fragen
und fröhliche Nervosität.
Alle wollen den Kilimandscharo
aus einem anderen Motiv besteigen.
Ich möchte hoch, weil ich
die Herausforderung und Afrika mag,
weil ich mal
aufs Dach von Afrika will,
weil ich die Challenge, die Höhe
selbst spüren und erleben will.
Ich hege diesen Traum
schon lange in mir.
Dieses Jahr befinde ich mich gerade
in einer Umbruchphase
und habe endlich Zeit,
diesen Traum anzugehen.
Es freut mich mega, dass der Traum
endlich in Erfüllung gehen darf.
Ich möchte gerne auf den Kili, weil
das so eine Lebens-Challenge ist,
etwas,
das man nur einmal im Leben macht,
weil man sicher an die Grenzen kommt
und schöne Dinge sieht.
Ich erhoffe mir, dass mich das
vom gewohnten Alltag trennt,
dass ich den Kopf lüften kann,
einen klaren Kopf bekomme.
Ich wandere sehr gerne.
Der Kilimandscharo
ist etwas Erreichbares für mich.
Ich mag nicht so gerne Schnee.
Mit Steigeisen und Pickel
ist nicht so meins.
Der Kilimandscharo ist machbar.
Solch eine lange
und hohe Wanderung
habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich bin gespannt, ob es geht.
Und ... ähm ... ja ...
Alle sagen immer:
"Pole, pole" - "langsam, langsam".
Das wird wohl
das Motto der Woche werden.
Ich weiss nicht,
in welcher Reihenfolge ...
(Verkäufer) Hakuna matata.
- (Alle) Hakuna matata.
"Hakuna matata" -
"alles kein Problem" -
auch das wird ein Moto werden
in diesen Tagen.
Alle sechs meldeten sich
auf einen Aufruf von SRF
und bezahlen ihre Reise selbst.
Was sagt man hier unten?
- Maisha marefu.
(Alle) Maisha marefu.
Sie wollen auch mehr
über ihre Begleiter am Berg wissen.
(Sandra) D.h., als Guide verdienst
du gut. Geht es dir gut als Guide?
Ja, es geht dir gut,
aber du brauchst Arbeit.
Die Konkurrenz ist extrem gross.
Du hast Hunderte Guides, aber nur
jeder Zehnte kann im Einsatz sein.
Ah, nur?
- Ja.
Kurt arbeitete lange
mit Priskus' Vater,
der wiederum zog seinen Sohn nach.
Priskus konnte vor vier Jahren
dieses Haus bauen.
Seit sein Vater gestorben ist,
ist er das Familienoberhaupt
und sorgt für seine zehn Geschwister,
auch für seine Schwester Brigit.
Sie hat sich spontan entschlossen,
die Tour mitzumachen.
Lucy und Priskus haben drei Söhne.
Die zwei älteren
sind auf einer Privatschule.
Priskus ist privilegiert.
Als leitender Bergführer
verdient er 250 ¤ pro Trip.
Ich konnte dieses Haus nur bauen,
da ich auf den Kilimandscharo gehe.
Meine Familie ist gesund,
weil ich Touren mache
und so Geld verdiene.
Das ist alles
nur wegen des Kilimandscharos.
Morgen gehen wir hoch.
Auch meine Nachbarn
kommen mit als Träger.
Das hilft ihnen.
Sie profitieren auch davon
und können so
ein anständiges Leben führen.
Weil Priskus sie zusätzlich
noch unterstützt,
hat es bisher weder für Innenausbau
noch für Fenster gereicht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Gruppe
ist ins Hotel zurückgekehrt.
More Than A Drop
ist eine Schweizer NGO,
die jungen Frauen
aus zerrütteten Verhältnissen
eine Ausbildung in der Hotellerie
ermöglicht.
Sie wohnen hier, lernen Englisch
und wie man serviert
und sich gegenüber Gästen verhält.
Priskus und sein Bruder Augustin
sind fürs Briefing gekommen.
Guten Abend zusammen.
- (Alle) Good evening.
Wie geht es euch? Alles okay?
(Kurt) Great.
- Okay.
Das ist Augustin,
der zweite Bergführer,
aber es kommen
noch fünf weitere mit,
insgesamt sind wir sieben Guides.
Das ist Brigit, meine Schwester.
Sie wird uns begleiten -
Schritt für Schritt
auf das Dach Afrikas.
Priskus gibt Tipps,
wie man es am besten schafft,
auf den Gipfel zu kommen.
Trinkt genügend Wasser.
Es wird verhindern,
dass ihr die Höhenkrankheit bekommt.
Die meisten Leute,
die schnell hinaufwollen,
bekommen Probleme, denn ihr Körper
hat nicht genügend Zeit,
um sich an die Höhe zu gewöhnen.
Einige Leute
schaffen es nicht auf den Gipfel,
weil sie zu viel denken.
Also bleibt immer optimistisch.
Sawa sawa? Another thing:
Ohne Fleiss kein Preis.
Der letzte Tag
auf dem Weg zum Gipfel:
Ihr fühlt euch müde,
euch ist schwindlig,
ihr habt Kopfschmerzen,
alles nervt und euch ist schlecht.
Das ist alles sehr normal.
Sawa sawa?
Eine klare Ansage.
Priskus' Bruder Augustin
übernimmt den Gepäck-Check.
Hello, how are you?
- Thanks, fine.
(Augustin) Hakuna matata. All good.
- (Daniel) Hakuna matata.
Ich friere wahnsinnig schnell
und bin irgendwie nicht gebaut
für kalte Temperaturen.
2'500 Fr. habe ich bezahlt, aber
dafür habe ich eine gute Ausrüstung,
bei der ich mir sicher bin,
dass alles funktioniert.
Thermowäsche,
die nicht schnell riecht und so.
Ich denke, damit
bin ich nicht schlecht ausgerüstet.
Die meisten Leute
nehmen zu viel mit, v.a. Esswaren.
Sie denken, es gebe nicht genug
zu essen am Kilimandscharo
und packen darum
zu viele Snacks ein.
Dann ist ihr Gepäck zu schwer.
Yes.
- Very?- Yes. Sure.
She ist ready.
Hier habe ich auch etwas Spezielles.
Eine Bekannte sagte mir,
dass man nach dem Zähneputzen
nicht immer mit Wasser spülen könne.
Ich habe aber eine Zahnpasta
mit Gin-Geschmack gefunden.
Die hat man gerne im Mund
und will sie nicht immer ausspülen.
* Dynamische Musik *
Endlich geht's los.
3 Std. Busfahrt
bis zum Start am Lemosho Gate.
* Dynamische Musik *
Die Gruppe besteigt
den Kilimandscharo in acht Tagen
und überwindet dabei gesamthaft
fast 6'000 Höhenmeter.
Vom Gate
geht es in den ersten drei Tagen
zum Big Tree Camp im Dschungel,
dann zum Shira Camp One
und von dort über die sog. Kathedrale
zum Shira Camp Two.
Am vierten Tag
geht es auf den Lava Tower
und wieder hinunter zum Baranco Camp.
Von dort über die Baranco Wall
zum Karanga und zum Barafu Camp,
von wo aus schliesslich der Aufstieg
auf den Uhuru Peak beginnt.
Die Lemosho-Route
ist die längste am Kilimandscharo,
für Nicht-Akklimatisierte
aber die sicherste,
weil sich der Körper
wegen der vielen Auf- und Abstiege
langsam an die Höhe gewöhnen kann.
Am Gate ist bereits viel los.
Die Gruppe ist nicht die einzige,
die loswill.
Priskus instruiert seine Träger.
Für die acht Tage am Berg
hat er 45 Träger angeheuert,
drei pro Person.
Das sind unsere Träger,
sie müssen in der Reihe stehen.
Später, bevor wir starten,
haben wir dort drüben eine Waage.
Sie müssen ihr Gepäck wägen.
Sie dürfen
nicht mehr als 20 kg tragen.
Priskus hat alle seine Bekannten
aufgeboten.
Jeder Träger verdient 15 ¤ am Tag.
Die Jobs sind heiss begehrt.
Wenn sie zu wenig Touren haben,
sind sie sehr traurig.
Ich bin auch gestresst,
wenn ich nicht genug Jobs habe.
Aber wenn ich genügend Touren habe -
etwa zwei bis drei
jeden Monat in der Hochsaison -,
dann kann ich mich entspannen.
Wir sind zu 100 %
von diesem Job abhängig.
Hello, hello.
Welcome, Lemosho Gate.
You are most welcome.
This is the Lemosho Gate.
Mister, you are welcome.
Lemosho Gate.
Priskus' Bruder Augustin
hilft beim Wägen.
(Priskus) Das ist die Waage.
Wenn sie hier wägen,
sind es manchmal mehr als 20 kg,
dann nehmen sie etwas heraus,
erst dann dürfen sie gehen.
Ob Zelte, Schlafmatten,
Küchenutensilien oder Esswaren -
alles muss kontrolliert, richtig
verpackt und hochgetragen werden.
Alle müssen sich
bei der Parkverwaltung registrieren.
Touristen
zahlen eine Parkgebühr von 1'100 ¤.
Ich spüre hier eine schöne Einheit -
noch.
Das bleibt so,
da haben wir keine Angst.
Wir haben es lustig.
- Ich bin auch optimistisch.
Das könnt ihr noch nicht sagen,
das wisst ihr nicht.
Es ist schön, zu sehen, wie sie,
auch schon auf der Hinfahrt,
Freude haben an der Landschaft,
an den Leuten.
Das macht sehr viel aus.
Einige kommen nur wegen des Berges.
Ich finde es nicht gut, wenn man
diese Reise nur deswegen macht.
Es gibt so viel zu sehen rundherum -
die schöne Landschaft,
die Leute, wie sie leben und sind,
das macht so viel aus.
Sandra
hat ein bisschen zu viel Ehrgeiz.
Ihr ist der Berg zu wichtig.
Sie dürfte ihre Erwartungen
ein bisschen runterschrauben.
Wenn du nicht raufkommen würdest,
bricht keine Welt zusammen.
Für mich schon.
- Dann nächstes Jahr wieder.
Nein, sobald das Kopfweh weg wäre,
würde ich hochgehen.
Es braucht Willen.
Man kann nicht einfach denken:
"Ich kann jetzt hier rauf
und alles ist gut."
Es braucht am Schluss
Willen, Überwindung und Biss.
Das Gepäck wird hochtransportiert,
die Gruppe darf noch nicht los.
Offenbar lief mit der Banküberweisung
für die Parkgebühr etwas schief.
Priskus
verhandelt mit der Parkverwaltung.
Es ist bald 16 Uhr und wir
können noch nicht in den Park.
Ich glaube, wir kommen
nicht mehr bei Helligkeit an.
Haben alle Lampen dabei?
- (Mehrere) Nein.
Ich habe sie dabei.
- Habt ihr hier eine Lampe?
Ich habe eine hier.
- Dann ist gut.
Wenn einer mit der Lampe vorausgeht,
reicht das.
Wir kommen schon zurecht.
Priskus' Schwester
sollte jetzt gehen,
die läuft nicht so schnell.
... back to Priskus
when I got to the landscape.
Priskus setzt bei der Parkverwaltung
alle Hebel in Bewegung,
aber es dauert.
* Suaheli *
Was, wenn alle Stricke reissen?
Wir können unsere Führer und Träger
wieder runterschicken.
Das wäre hart für sie,
aber wir würden ihnen
ein höheres Trinkgeld geben.
Ist Priskus jetzt oben mit ihnen?
Nein, nur ein Teil unserer Träger
ist schon oben.
Und unser Gepäck.
- Ja, unser Gepäck sahen wir.
Ja, ja, aber das
brauchen wir zum Schlafen.
Dann würden wir hier schlafen?
- Ja.
30 Min. später.
Gibt es gute Nachrichten?
Ja, freudige Überraschung:
Wir können gehen, das Geld ist da.
* Sie verabschieden sich. *
Nach 4 Std. Warten:
Endlich, das Abenteuer kann beginnen.
Es ist 16.30 Uhr.
Bis zum ersten Camp sind es knapp
700 Höhenmeter und 3 Std. Marsch.
Zweifarbig.
Als Landwirtin hat Ursula
ein besonderes Auge für die Natur.
Das wäre es.- Warte schnell.
Antippen und jetzt fotografieren.
Eine Wildbiene
habe ich auch gesehen.- Was?
Eine Wildbiene. Schon möglich,
dass es hier Wildbienen hat.
Hier sind wir zusammen, aber ich
kann mich auch herausnehmen.
Das werden wohl alle mal tun,
aber ich fühle mich wohl.
Ich fühle mich wohl
bei diesen Leuten hier.
Bisher passt es gut.
Ich merke, dass wir auf dem Säntis
gestartet sind,
schon auf 2'400 m ü.M. -
das ist aussergewöhnlich.
Sonst ist der Säntis die Zielhöhe,
heute der Start, aber es geht gut.
(Flüsternd) Seht mal!
(Flüsternd) Mitten auf der Strasse,
auf dem Weg.
(Flüsternd)
Hier sieht man noch besser.
Schaut,
wie er zu uns hinunterblickt.
(Flüsternd) Schau, jetzt geht er.
Das ist ein Riesenviech.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Sandra) Ein Rockstar.
- Unglaublich.
Ich finde es extrem eindrücklich,
wie sie ruhig dastehen,
nicht weggehen
und eine solche Ruhe ausstrahlen.
Das ist
ein richtiges Spektakel hier.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich bin sehr berührt. Damit
habe ich heute nicht gerechnet.
Es ist megaschön.
Ach, es schaudert einen richtig.
So kann es herausrutschen.
Du musst durch die beiden Bändel,
oben- und untendurch,
und dann fest anziehen.
Dafür haben wir die Männer dabei -
weil es Gentlemen sind.
Nein, Scherz.
(Fabian) So.
- (Sandra) Schau!
(Fabian) Ah, sieh an.
- (Sandra) Jö.
(Sandra) Danke vielmals.
- (Fabian) Gerne.
(Damaris)
Er lässt sich auf die Äste raus.
(Sandra) Der Pflücker.
- So etwas Schönes.
* Sanfte Musik:
"Africa" von Kosinus *
Es ist steil.
Noch geht es, doch.
Aber es muss
nicht immer so steil sein.
Ich bin froh, wenn wir nicht
zu lange im Dunkeln laufen müssen.
Das ist nicht mein Favorit.
Darum versuche ich,
ein bisschen zu beissen.
Sodass wir schnell oben sind.
* Sanfte Musik:
"Africa" von Kosinus *
Das Big Tree Camp auf 2'650 m.
Kili!
- (Fotograf) Kilimandscharo!
Das machen wir nun an jedem Point.
Ich suche unser Zuhause.
Ich habe es noch nicht gefunden.
Dort unten könnte es sein.
- Dani, erstes Camp!
So, geschafft!
- Here we go.
Jetzt müssen wir das Zelt suchen.
- Das ist doch deiner, oder?- Ja.
Es kommt mir vor
wie früher in einem Sommerlager.
Ich konnte nicht einschätzen,
wie voll es sein wird
mit all den Leuten,
weil es mehrere Gruppen
mit vielen Leuten sind.
Alle Porters
brauchen ja auch ein Zelt.
Im grossen Zelt sind alle.
Das ist wohl das Porter-Zelt.
Ah!
(Ursula) Hier sind wir zu Hause?
(Kurt) Wir zeigen uns,
damit sie uns finden.
Wir haben Affen-Stopps eingelegt,
das war ein Spektakel.
Wir haben eine Familie gesehen
mit so einem kleinen Baby.
Also wirklich zum Knuddeln.
Ohne Witz, es war gut, dass wir
so spät los sind.- Ja, eindeutig.
Das war das Beste,
das wir machen konnten.- Ja.
Die durchschnittliche
Campingerfahrung ist gering.
Drei, vier Tage an einem Open Air
war das Längste.
Sonst campen mit dem Bus,
aber das ist komfortabler
als mit dem Zelt.
Ja.
Aber das sieht
auch ganz komfortabel aus hier.
Ich bin wirklich überrascht:
Wir kommen an,
alles ist aufgebaut,
die Matratzen liegen drin.
Wir werden nur noch
zum Zelt geführt.
Das ist ein Topservice,
den diese Leute hier leisten.
(Kurt) Findet ihr unser Zelt?
Sonst ruft ihr, dann hören wir euch.
Kurt hat den Berg
mindestens 50-mal bestiegen.
Er fühlt sich zu Hause.
Zeit für einen Apéro.
Herrenabend.
Klaus?- Kurt, ja.
- Wo sind wir?- Hier.
Kurt?- Gut, ja?
- Muss ich etwas mitnehmen?
Gute Laune.
Davon haben wir zu 100 % genug
nach einem so coolen Tag.
Schuhe ausziehen,
wer ins Zelt kommt.
Zufrieden, sehr zufrieden.
Mich beeindruckte
die anfängliche Unruhe,
weil wir unsicher waren,
ob wir noch in den Berg kommen.
Kaum hatten wir
die ersten Colobus Monkeys gesehen,
war die Gruppe ruhig
und es wurde alles fast meditativ.
I am sorry.
- (Alle) Cheers. Zum Wohl. Cin cin.
Das ist eine neue Route.
Vor zehn Jahren
gab es hier keinen Weg.
Das haben sie extra gemacht, damit
sie eine interessante Route haben,
die gut fürs Akklimatisieren ist.
Das beeindruckt mich auch sehr.
Für unsere Gruppe hier
nehmen wir n-mal drei Leute mit.
Es braucht aber auch für jeden
einen Schlafplatz und Essen.
Ihre eigenen Sachen
müssen sie auch dabeihaben.
Das ist fast eine
exponentielle Vermehrung oder Kurve.
Genau.
- Das ist unglaublich.
Das stimmt,
sie haben nur ein grosses Zelt
und essen nur Ugali und Kabis.
Was ist Ugali?
- Das ist dieser Maisbrei.
So haben sie
viel weniger Gewicht mit dem Essen.
Sie sind viel genügsamer.
Sie haben heute
die schweren Lasten raufgetragen,
aber zuerst kochen sie,
damit wir essen können.
Erst nachdem wir gegessen haben,
essen sie.
Das ist Wahnsinn, so genügsam.
- Das ist krass unfair.
Der Gap zwischen Touristen
und Trägern ist augenfällig
und wird ein Thema bleiben.
Am ersten Abend aber
sind alle zu müde
für tiefgründige Diskussionen.
Gleich nach dem Abendessen
ist Nachtruhe.
(Fabian) Gute Nacht.
- (Alle) Schlaft gut.
Am nächsten Morgen kurz vor 7 Uhr:
Es ist gerade einmal 4 °C warm.
Ich hatte schon bessere Nächte,
aber es war nicht schlecht.
Es war schwierig,
die Temperatur zu regulieren.
Ich fror und hatte dann
wieder heiss, aber es war ganz okay.
Guten Morgen.
Hey, wie habt ihr gepennt?
Wer schnarcht denn so laut?
(Fabian) Ich sicher nicht.
- Doch, das warst du, garantiert.
Ich hätte fast geklopft:
"Sei mal ruhig!"
So schlimm?
- Ja.
Er fand es nicht so schlimm.
- Doch, es war wirklich schlimm.
Ich hörte dann Musik.
A new day.
- Yes, it is a new day.
Priskus' Schwester Brigit musste
gestern vor Erschöpfung weinen.
Jetzt geht es ihr wieder gut.
Morgenprogramm.
Für dringende Bedürfnisse
gibt es zwei blaue WC-Zelte.
Sandra hat es sich mit
Permanent-Make-up einfach gemacht.
Das ist wohl meine erste Reise,
auf die ich weder Pinsel
noch Schminke mitgenommen habe.
Auf einem Survival-Trip
braucht man das ja nicht.
Dann darf man auch mal
nicht ganz so aussehen wie sonst.
Es lebt sich genau gleich so.
Es ist absolut kein Problem.
Ich habe nicht einmal Gesichtscreme
dabei, Sonnencreme fettet ja auch.
Und Lippenpomade -
mehr eigentlich nicht.
Ich staune darüber, dass die Männer
mit Rasierer usw. ausgerüstet sind.
Es hat eitle Leute in der Gruppe.
- Zu denen gehöre ich nicht.
Was muss, das muss.
- Ja, ja, das sehe ich auch so.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ich esse morgens nie Nutella
und bekomme nie solche Sachen.
Wir gehen wohl
nicht mehr nach Hause.
Es ist 8 Uhr.
5 Std. Wanderung liegen vor ihnen.
Ich muss bleiben, um zu schauen,
dass hier alles aufgeräumt ist
und stosse dann im Busch zu euch.
Sawa sawa?
- (Alle) Sawa sawa.Gute Wanderung.
(Damaris) Thank you.
- (Priskus) Yes.
Das waren sicher die.
Einer wollte ins Zelt kommen.
Vom Big Tree Camp
geht's 10 km und 900 Höhenmeter
zum Shira Camp One auf 3'500 m.
Hello.
(Damaris)
Oh, kommen wir hier in die Steppe?
(Daniel) Das sieht ganz so aus.
- Ganz eine andere Vegetation.
Für Klaus ist Trekken etwas Neues.
Es ist das erste Mal überhaupt,
dass der Anästhesist und Rega-Arzt
ohne seine Familie Ferien macht.
Es prasselt plötzlich
so viel auf mich ein.
Ich merke,
dass es mir extrem guttut,
mal aus diesem durchstrukturierten
Alltag rauszukommen,
mal wieder etwas ganz anderes
zu machen und zu erleben
und so einen richtigen Break
zu haben.
Klaus ist ein Familienmensch
und schon lange verheiratet.
Jetzt, wo die Kinder grösser werden,
verändert sich einiges.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das meine Midlife-Crisis ist.
Die Mädchen sind dieses Jahr 18
geworden und der Sohnemann ist 15.
Der kam jetzt auch aus der Sek.
Alle Kinder sind aus der Schule.
Es ist vielleicht schon
eine Umbruchzeit.
Vielleicht ist nach all den Jahren
auch der Moment gekommen,
in dem man sich überlegt,
ob man in eine neue Richtung möchte
oder ob man etwas anderes braucht -
nochmals eine Challenge im Leben.
Vor einem Jahr
zog Klaus darum die Konsequenzen,
kündigte im Spital
und machte sich selbstständig.
Seither arbeitet er
als Anästhesist auf Abruf
in Praxen und Spitäler
und ist sein eigener Chef.
* Suaheli *
Priskus' Schwester Brigit kämpft.
Es ist anstrengend.
Ich habe wenig Übung.
Aber es tut gut.
Ich bin so stolz auf meine Brüder,
die hier am Schuften sind,
und auf meinen Vater im Himmel.
Sie machen das für mich und für uns,
damit wir
eine gute Ausbildung haben.
They are the best.
Mit all den Lasten
auf den Schultern.
Sie alle sind Superhelden.
Schau mal, die schöne Aussicht!
Wow!
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir gehen nur aufwärts und rüber.
- Schon auch hinunter.
Der Shira bildet mit dem Kibo
und dem Mawenzi zusammen
das Kilimandscharo-Massiv.
Der Kibo ist mit 5'895 m
der höchste Punkt.
Dort wollen alle hin.
Schon 3 Std.
ist die Truppe unterwegs.
Ursula nimmt's gemütlich.
Sie arbeitet viel draussen und
ist körperliche Anstrengung gewohnt.
Auf den Kili wollte sie schon,
als ihre Kinder noch klein waren.
Erwartungen habe ich generell keine.
Es bringt mir viele Eindrücke.
"Horizonterweiterung"
könnte man das nennen.
Es ist kein Leistungsding,
hier oben gewesen zu sein.
Es ist ein Erlebnis,
das ich jetzt machen durfte.
Das ist die Freude am Ganzen.
Obwohl sie zu Hause viel wandert:
Hier geht's nicht so einfach,
wie sie gedacht hat.
Ich bin müde,
Kopfweh habe ich auch ein bisschen.
Es geht schon,
ich muss einfach langsam gehen.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie die anderen rennen können,
aber ich habe mein Tempo
und so geht es.
Wird das Kopfweh schlimmer?
- Nein, es wird nicht schlimmer.
Es ist einfach noch da.
Gestern war es mehr als heute.
Ja, aber es geht schon.
Ich muss mich einfach konzentrieren.
Manchmal bin ich etwas wacklig,
habe ich den Eindruck.
Auch Ursula hat ihr Leben
vor zwei Jahren radikal verändert:
Sie liess sich scheiden
und zog aus dem gemeinsamen Haus aus.
Ihre zwei Mädchen sind erwachsen.
Nun hat sie Zeit,
die Welt neu zu entdecken.
Es ist so vieles offen für mich,
auch reisen.
Ich redete immer übers Reisen,
ging aber nie.
Es ergab sich vorher auch nicht.
Ich arbeitete mit den Kindern
und hatte Spass.
Jetzt sind viele Türen aufgegangen,
die ich ausprobieren kann
und auch wieder schliessen kann,
wenn es nicht passt.
Ich bin extrem frei.
* Sanfte Musik *
Jede und jeder läuft sein Tempo.
Auf dem Shira-Plateau ist die Gruppe
zeitweise kilometerweit auseinander.
Doch überall ist ein Guide
in der Nähe, falls etwas wäre.
Damaris hatte vor einigen Jahren
massive Rückenprobleme.
Unvorstellbar damals, ein solches
Trekking in Angriff zu nehmen.
Schon mit 14 hatte ich diesen Traum.
Er rutschte dann ab und zu
in den Hintergrund.
In den letzten Jahren
habe ich das Wandern wiederentdeckt
und gemerkt,
dass ich beim Wandern bei mir bin.
Dann wusste ich: Es ist Zeit,
auf diesen Berg zu gehen.
Die Hebamme ist Single
und steht an einem völlig anderen
Punkt im Leben als die anderen.
Soeben hat sie
ihr Studium abgeschlossen
und geniesst ihre Unabhängigkeit.
Ich versuche megafest,
im Moment zu leben
und das Leben so zu nehmen,
wie es ist.
Wenn mal eine Beziehung kommt,
dann nehme ich die,
wenn es das Richtige ist -
und wenn nicht,
kann ich ganz viel anderes tun, das
ich sonst wohl nicht machen würde.
Das zu wissen, ist wohl auch etwas,
das mir viel Lebensfreude gibt.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck,
etwas zu verpassen.
Jede Möglichkeit im Leben
bietet mir etwas Schönes.
Nicht dem nachtrauern,
das man vielleicht nicht hat.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Shira Camp One
arbeiten die Träger
bereits wieder auf Hochtouren.
Verantwortlich
für Übernachtung und Essen
ist Augustin, Priskus' Bruder.
Das sind die Campingmanager.
Sie müssen schnell laufen können,
damit sie alles vorbereiten können
für die Touristen.
Wer zuerst kommt, hat den Platz.
Es gibt keine Parkregel.
Sie sagen zwar, sie lassen nicht
mehr als 200 Leute rein pro Tag,
aber es gibt keine Buchungen,
darum weiss man nie.
Manchmal kommen 300 -
da kann man nichts machen.
Man kann sie
ja nicht zurückschicken.
Und wir mögen es,
wenn viele Touristen kommen.
Fast wie im Hotel:
Das Gepäck wird aufs Zimmer gebracht,
jede und jeder bekommt eine Matte.
Als Erste kam Sandra an.
Wie lief es?- Super.
Es war eine coole Wanderung.
Ich staune darüber,
dass es so gut ging.
Beim Hochlaufen
konnten wir noch miteinander reden.
Wir hatten es lustig.
Es ging wirklich super.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
- Ging es allen gut?
Hm, das weiss ich nicht.
Gewisse sind noch nicht da.
Es gab eine Art Orgel:
Die Schnelleren sind schon hier,
und die, die es gemütlicher nehmen,
sind noch am Laufen.
Hakuna matata.
- Hakuna matata, bravo.
Ursula, auguri!
- Ein bisschen alles.- Well done.
Am Brustkasten drückte es
und hier drückte es
und hier zog es und hier.
Die Schenkel waren plötzlich so
müde, das wurde wieder besser.- Ja.
(Kurt) Gut? Gratuliere.
- Heute Abend peppen wir dich auf.
Ja, es fiel mir nicht so leicht
wie euch, aber ich bin hier.
Beim letzten steilen Stück
kam ich gröber an den Anschlag.
Das sind Anpassungserscheinungen.
Du hast Kopfweh
und dann wieder nicht mehr.
Da passt sich der Körper
ein wenig an.
Ich habe immer ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Das scheint dazuzugehören.
Es ist hier.
Das ist vielleicht
nicht mal die Höhe.
Vielleicht ist es verspannt, weil
man immer runter- oder hochschaut.
Endlich haben die Träger Pause.
Alle essen Ugali, ihren Maisbrei.
Das ist unser Hauptnahrungsmittel
am Berg.
Wenn ich dem Küchenchef sage,
er soll für die Träger Pasta kochen,
schätzen sie das nicht.
Wir mögen Ugali, das macht stark.
Ich kann mir momentan
überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
wo es dann aufhört.
Dort, wo du die Kante siehst
am Horizont, wo es steil ist,
dort geht es noch mehr rüber.
- (Daniel) Wir laufen hinten durch.
(Kurt)
Wir laufen noch mehr gegen Osten.
Wenn du so läufst,
kommst du nach Mombasa.
Und erst weiter vorne
gehen wir steil nach oben.
Sie machen
einen sehr guten Eindruck.
Sie nehmen es locker.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl.
Aber das heisst noch nichts.
Wir sind erst bei Tag 2.
Das kann natürlich
noch anders kommen.
Jetzt zeigt er sich.
Kommt schauen!
Mit Schnee.
- Yeah, man sieht ihn.
Nein, es hat noch Schnee.
- Mit Schnee.
Wir sind extra nach Afrika
und jetzt haben wir Schnee.
(Daniel) Unvorstellbar,
dass wir bald dort sind.
(Kurt) Du meinst "bald"?
Es wird dann noch ein Krampf.
(Daniel) Er wirkt noch so fern.
(Kurt) Wir reden in zwei Tagen,
dann sind wir nahe.
Wir sind noch nicht in der Hälfte.
- Das habe ich ignoriert.
Ich habe mich auf die Schönheit
des Berges konzentriert.
Der Berg das erste Mal
in seiner vollen Pracht.
Sechs Tage liegen noch vor ihnen.
Werden sie es schaffen?
Und was hat es
mit Ursulas Beschwerden auf sich?
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023